so we're fine tuning
your ground path
on the mid foot okay so you're going to
go and the first thing you want to do
is drop your weight
onto the mid
foot of each foot okay
so this leg i'm going to
don't let this curl on you push that
down
and
projecting energy on the inside without
doing that to your foot you're rolling
the arch up
spread your metatarsals
okay now just as i come to apply
pressure
don't change your posture okay so if you
for example brace against me you see and
then it's not there
so you put your weight on there
stay there
let's have you turn your head more
straight
just try to get this knee and ankle here
and don't unweight this foot
and you're a little turned you see
turn your hips there you go
up
okay now don't brace on me
take this energy
and let it pass through you by relaxing
the legs not relaxing this part yet
don't do that
extend past me
okay
so
what you're doing now is you're pushing
against me this way
this hand you're you're pushing against
it like right here
so keep this hand alive to not over yawn
this hand keep both hands alive
concentrating on this right hand
your mind put your mind more on the
right hand
reach past me with
your my left hand reach past my left
hand but concentrate on this hand
don't your shoulders are going back so
don't
unflex your core
the core goes all the way around your
body and you're doing the lean again
you see
oh
so that lean even though it's not an
a-frame is a bracing
uh angle okay and then we're not doing
that
okay
weight is on
keep spread your metatarsals your foot
bones
and this what is two is too far out like
this okay
keep your eyes out don't let it pull
your chin too down
okay reach out past me
don't you're already going to your heels
okay you're already going to your heels
reach out past me touch past me to stop
the weight going to your heels
come on
reach past me there you go reach past me
with your mind too
don't let go of this hand
keep this intention here it's starting
to turn you
keep reaching on this hand your left
hand
whoa you see it's going to your heels
your toes are light you feel the toes
are light you see
handheld hold the camera
and then again get in position
okay
so try to get this to come straight
so
the only way you can get this angle on
like a bracing angle you can't see the
angle on your ankle
is that you relaxed here
okay
a little bit more this way
try to keep that straight
whatever what i mean is straight out of
the foot
do you see you don't want a can
you don't want to can't straight out of
the foot straight out of the way
but not by my
not by my leg being straight
okay my knee is going to bend
you see my knee is going to bend but
it's straight out of my foot
so i'm not straight out of my foot by
straightening my leg my knee bends
but my ankle stays straight so it's not
my knee bends and my ankle bends
my knee
my foot turns this way
straight drop your weight on that foot
pay attention to this arm to help you
try not to lean into that try not to
lean into this arm that's why i want you
to focus on this reach
reach
be strong on this side so that this
doesn't dominate
reach more your mind here go past me
watch your ankles starting to to do that
thing okay
all right here we go
here
and there's this brace
and then there's the brace you see
okay
okay so i'm taking my weight which is
energy and i'm putting it on those spots
of both my feet okay and so when he
pushes i don't move
and when he pulls
i don't move he pushes i don't move he
pulls i don't move he pushes i don't
move he pulls i don't
not going there
he pulls i'm not going here
okay
i'm here he pushes
he pulls
no
pushes i stay same grounding he goes and
i say the same ground he goes oh and you
see who's moving go oh he's moving he
goes
you get it okay so um
what we have to do
is once you get your weight
in the right place it's emotional
when you start feeling him you start
pushing back on him and now you're not
in the right place so um
this is why when i let go of this arm
that's why you fell that way you see
so it's emotional you work you
got you in the right place but as soon
as he comes here you start pushing
against him and now you're not standing
like i had you anymore you see and so if
you change direction on me oh you're
gonna get me okay
so
don't get emotional
just brace you can you can totally
ignore him
your weight is down on those spots he
goes and just down on those spots he
goes he's down in those spots
so it's he's not stepping out of like
boom and then he steps it's because he's
what he pushes into me
he goes well it's making him when he
tries to pull that hat it's no different
get your base it's no different than i
do enough it goes into his
uh home and now when he pushes when he
pushes here go ahead get back there he
pushes here
it's making him do that do you see that
so that's how he's here he goes i don't
care and he pushed his ball then he goes
oh and he goes boom and he goes and he
goes
okay
so
what you're not noticing is that
right when he comes in
it's triggering you mean you're having
an emotional reaction and then that
triggering
changes your weight distribution and now
you're not mid-foot and you don't
realize it okay all right let's try it
go
so when you're doing this training
remember like when i i get all in
position and then you'll see i did that
on my purchase all right as i get ready
for you and i got i changed it you see
if you let go and i stay here you can
see
oh
i brought the dead angle in front of me
just from that little
anticipation and the triggering
of you as a threat okay
so
my emotional reactivity
will change my posture
got it okay
another one that happens is when you
start to feel your arms
you see like doing that and so what then
i i feel that as a threat are you
starting to push and then you'll see
look what i did
you see as i try to deal with that now
if you let go and i stay here just let
go and you see that i stay here i don't
have midfoot
again i had that
dead egg okay
when you when you realize it's go ahead
just keep keep pushing keep pushing it
doesn't matter what my hands are doing
i'm i'm staying that posture do you see
that at no point i don't feel threatened
by what you're doing i stay in this
posture
keep pushing keep pushing i don't i
don't ever feel threatened by it
by what you're doing stay in this
posture that's how you can
move things around okay so i want you to
understand
that
when you guys feel your arms losing what
you think
is losing
you feel threatened
and then you change your posture and
you're not realizing okay so i want to
give you some tips
but i want you to understand it's not
supposed to matter
where your hands are
that's what i just tried to demonstrate
you're pushing you're pushing
it doesn't matter what my hands are
doing there's no there's no
point where
i feel threatened by you i'm just
grounded
you see there's no point
where you can keep my hands okay so okay
i'll put that on the back burner i'm
gonna show you some tricks okay so you
guys go like this and it starts to
threaten you
so what i want you to do
is understand the grip dynamics
don't let your mind
go
into their hand
or into this side of their grip
i want your mind to go to the other side
of their grip
i want you to reach past it
and around it
okay
you'll get some mechanical advantage by
bringing your elbow under
but it's really the fact that your mind
goes i'm gonna go past it
okay
so i'm gonna go past it
and i'm gonna touch you
do you see that because right now i feel
like you're getting me
so
you're it's starting to go
uh oh and you start to adjust to get it
you see i did that instead of doing that
adjust and before it gets into your
elbow i want you to turn it
you put your mind past it and touch them
do you understand so starting to go
touch reach out past the grip
pass the grip and touch them do you see
that so that you're not triggered into
doing this kind of thing you can't even
start that way you're going to grab me
and i reach out and i touch you
you see i'm touching you i'm trying to
spill over your
grip you got it because i don't want to
do these shifting
bracing angles okay
all right